russia flexing its military muscle just
50 kilometers from the belarusian border
with ukraine
for weeks troops have been arriving even
from russia's far east 10 000 kilometers
away it is clear that this is far bigger
than previous military exercises while
russian officials have not disclosed the
number of soldiers involved nato speaks
of thirty thousand
if you consider that
an invasion of a large territory like
ukraine is in putin's interest to have
the chance to attack from the south from
marine and
crimea forces
from the east from russian soil and from
the north in a joint action of russia
and its ally belarus
so militarily speaking it couldn't be
any better
footage released by russian ministry of
defense showed tanks and missile
launchers being used in the drills and
military jets in the air
from the belarusian border with ukraine
it is less than a two-hour drive to the
capital kiev western leaders worry if
this is a serious drill or a ploy for a
real attack for the next 10 days the
world's eyes will be on the largest
russian contingent on belarusian soil in
decades a possible second front for
vladimir putin who makes use of the
isolated and international weak position
of its prodigy alexander lukashenka
lukashenga came under sanctions from the
west after he was accused of election
fraud and a violent crackdown on the
opposition while the belarusian leader
has always stressed the independence of
belarus and refrain from condoning
putin's military actions in crimea and
eastern ukraine he has now turned to the
russian leader for help
military forces have always left belarus
after the end of an exercise right now
there are more participants and the
rhetoric is aggressive i think
lukashenko's attitude is caused by his
annoyance with the west and the fact it
doesn't recognise him as a legitimate
leader he believes russian troops will
eventually leave after the drills finish
on february 20 until then speculation
about the real purpose of this show or
force will likely continue step faster
al jazeera in minsk